[Music]
if you have a not so green thumb like me
you'll love this tip from a plant expert
here's plant stylist my favorite hilton
carter you gotta take a look when you
decide to water your plant just like
others you're to do it nice and easy
slow and steady around the entire pot
making sure that every single root in
there has a moment to pull in moisture
that is important and because you
haven't watered this desert plant in
weeks
it's going to need to be watered
completely through all the way through
all the roots and all the way down into
your base tray now we're talking about
water water for the snake plant is one
of the reasons
people kill it over watering so you want
to be aware of that signs of an over
water snake plant is soft yellowing
tissue as you can see all of the tissue
is turning very yellow and very mushy
and then when it leans like that that is
a clear sign that it has been over
watered and now it is dying but an
underwater snake plant leaf will show
signs of just let's say browning dry
brownie on the edge of the foliage but
if that happens what you can do here is
you can kind of trim that off you can
use your nail maybe trim that off and
there it is it's gone and now you still
have the rest of your leaf looking great
but if you over water there's nothing
really you can do here
so once you see dyeing foliage happen
like this this is probably a good time
to start pruning that plant back to at
least give all of the foliage that still
has good life in it the time the moment
to
really grow to really thrive
i need more hilton carter in my life
chip and joanna where can i find him
well he hosts the guide to house plants
and caring for common house plants
workshops on the magnolia app where you
can grow your houseplant skills well
thumbs up for green thumb
[Music]
you